We are seeing a broken man falling apart more
and more acutely every single day.
Donald Trump's presidency is now in its death
throes, and Donald Trump himself has been
increasingly unhinged, retweeting garbage
right wing media clips to his Twitter while
being missing in action as president of the
United States for months now.
And over the weekend, he unleashed a tweet
storm so unhinged, so outrageous that it's
hard to imagine what he's going to do when
the day finally comes that he is no longer
president of the United States.
This is really bad for the country, truly
bad.
And it's not just humiliating for Trump, it's
humiliating for the country globally.
They are crying for us.
Yes, because of the covid mishandling and
the unnecessary death and suffering.
They are scared for us.
Yes, because we have such anti-democratic
forces coming out of the woodwork in the Republican
Party.
But they're also laughing at us because we
have a president technically anyway for a
few more days who can't stop tweeting trash
after trash that almost no world leader would
ever be caught dead, tweeting Trump again,
ranting about so-called dead voters who don't
exist, tweeting, why haven't they done signature
verification in Fulton County, Georgia?
Why haven't they deducted all of the dead
people who voted illegals who voted non Georgia
residents who voted and tens of thousands
of others who voted illegally from the final
vote tally?
These are all lies.
Just a small portion of these votes.
Give us a big and conclusive win in Georgia.
Have they illegally destroyed ballots in Fulton
County after many weeks?
We don't yet even have a judge to hear this
large scale voter fraud case.
The only judge seems to be Stacy's sister,
referring to Stacey Abrams.
Trump insisting he won in a landslide, saying
about a Ted Cruz tweet that this is, quote,
an attempt to steal a landslide win.
Can't let it happen.
Trump attacking Georgia Republican officials
who are now the enemy because they won't overtly
steal the election.
Remember, for all the praise of Brad Raffensperger
and these other Georgia Republicans who are
unwilling to do what Trump wants, they were
very willing to try to steal the election
via voter suppression.
In fact, Georgia was sort of one of one of
the central places of purging voter rolls
and and shutting down polling places like
Georgia is.
The Georgia Republicans are very willing to
do some terrible stuff.
They just weren't willing to do it this way
after the fact.
And Trump is now attacking them, saying, quote,
Republicans in Georgia must be careful of
the political corruption in Fulton County,
which is rampant.
The governor, Brian Kemp, and his puppet,
Lieutenant Governor Jeff Duncan, have done
less than nothing.
They are a disgrace to the great people of
Georgia and Donald Trump.
Just continuing to tweet lies about Georgia,
saying, quote, Georgia election data just
revealed shows that over 17000 votes illegally
flipped from Trump to Biden.
This alone, there are many other irregularities,
is enough to easily swing Georgia to Trump.
Quoting on none of that is true.
There's no evidence for any of that.
No court has found any of these arguments
meritorious or with evidence.
Trump then interrupting the election tweets
to attack Dr. Anthony Fauci saying, quote,
Somehow Dr. Fauci is revered by the lame stream
media as such a great professional, having
done, they say, such an incredible job.
Yet he works for me in the Trump administration,
and I am in no way given any credit for my
work.
Gee, could this just be more fake news?
Of course.
Trump the theme as Trump continuing to be
triggered by Dr. Fauci being more respected
and trusted than Trump.
And when Trump says Foushee works for me,
I should get the credit.
Well, you've been advocating for the opposite
of Foushee in many cases and attacking him
publicly for months now.
That's why you're not getting the accolades
for for being the person who allows Foushee
to remain in your employ.
And then Trump continuing to spread more lies
about the virus, which have deadly consequences,
saying, quote, The number of cases and deaths
of the China virus is far exaggerated in the
United States because of the CDC's ridiculous
method of determination compared to other
countries, many of whom report purposely,
very inaccurately and low when in doubt.
Call it covid fake news.
Now, that one is not only untrue, if anything,
the number is understated.
There's a new CDC report that says, OK, we
have the official number.
Which is around three hundred and fifty thousand
dead from covid already a tragedy, but we
suspect that the real number is more like
half a million for reasons we've already discussed.
So when Trump says the real death toll is
lower, he implies it's less dangerous than
it is, which encourages people to disregard
guidelines which save lives.
And then Donald Trump retweeting a tweet from
lawyer Sidney Powell, who he supposedly doesn't
have anything to do with saying, quote, This
election was stolen from the voters in a massive
fraud that you and others are now complicit
in.
American elections are supposed to be completely
auditable and transparent.
We the people demand the truth and the prosecutions
of all who committed voter fraud.
And then Trump lastly tweeting that he will
be there at a historic day on Wednesday, a
march to stop the steal and not to certify
the 2020 election.
I won't keep going.
This is just a sampling.
This is not a well person, but he will be
gone soon.
The more important issue is that this is really
bad for the country and its negative effects
are going to persist beyond January 20th.
And we're going to have significantly more
coverage about that coming up later this week,
but also in later months.